welcome back everybody to las vegas now
the strat recently got more mesmerizing
they've added the banner checks mind
games live
to their list of entertainment and of
course we had to get banner checked our
subs do you like that tagline i do like
that
for you no i love it it's great yeah no
no no i'm a mind reader you are you are
you are a mentalist so explain what that
means so a mentalist if somebody takes a
five known sentences create the illusion
of a sixth sense i'm not a psychic i use
verbal nonverbal communication
psychology and lots of magic to
duplicate what psychics appear to do
all right i'm ready so what can we
expect at the show and then i want you
to kind of put me to the test so at the
show what i'm doing is i'm taking a mind
reading to new heights for the strat
right it's a 4 p.m show which means you
can bring the kids as well at six and up
you can bring them on in and they'll
fully understand what i do because it's
like a super power show i bring a kid up
and he's actually bending silverware
there's a little bit of a scary part at
the end where i put my life on the line
we play russian roulette with knives and
then i also perform the biggest mind
reading show in the world and what i
mean by that it's a mind reading
experiment everybody writes down their
name their initials the thought about
themselves fold it up bring it to the
show and i will tell you exactly what
you're thinking oh my gosh it's so much
fun you guys seriously it just you'll
leave feeling completely unsure about
reality right yep let's try something
with you so i have a guy we are in las
vegas take a look make sure all the
numbers are on there okay this isn't
going to involve any math right no no
math but we're going to do it we're
going to do three things with this so we
need to make it fairly fast so put it on
the table you've taken a look seeing all
the numbers on there i want you and i'm
going to step back just a little bit i
want you to think of number between one
and six and then i need you to put it
with that number upright and cover it
with both hands if you could for me can
you do that
one hand's fine but just as soon as
there's no way i could see it i'm going
to look the other way i'm sorry say it
one more time put your number upwards on
it yeah and keep it covered because i'm
going to turn around tell me when you're
done okay i'm done
have you ever played any dice games
before yeah then you're not going to go
with a one or a six you're probably
going to go somewhere in the middle you
won't go with an odd number because
another would be trying to trick me you
probably went with uh let's see high
number would be four did you put it on a
four
i did you did what in the world let's do
it again real quick do it again okay
okay cause we're dealing with your
conscious mind right now all right
tell me when you're done
okay i'm ready you're done all right
so i said you wouldn't put it on a one
last time trying to get into your head
and psyche you're out hoping you would
actually put it on a one did you put it
on a one what the heck
yes i did i did so we're gonna do it one
more time real quick because we don't
have a lot of time on the bottom is the
six top is one two is over there five
over there four and a three so
consciously and subconscious you know
where every number is
it's important you don't know what
number it's going to be this time so
cover it again and every time i say
switch you're just going to switch it
without even looking so you don't even
know what number's on top
go ahead and switch
which again okay
and switch again
okay and keep it covered all right
uh-huh so look at me if i asked you what
number was on top what would you say
five that would be a guess wouldn't it
yeah but look at me i'm gonna name
numbers just say no is it a five
just say no just say no no is it a three
no
is it a one no okay see i if you saw
that at home i don't know if you could
see that it was definitely a no on the
one you put on a one again
oh my gosh okay this is why you're the
world's greatest mentalist clearly so
how can people see the show so people
come to the strat you can get it at the
strat box office you can go online and
book your seats right there again it is
a 4 p.m show and you can bring the kids
to make sure you bring the kids there's
some fantastic shows there right now spy
entertainment has xavier mortimer who
comes on right after me he's a magician
so come see my show stick around for the
rest of the shows we got illuminate late
at night so yeah okay the strat is
definitely where it's at and
congratulations this is your first time
headlining on the strip it is my first
time headlining well actually i've
actually been in shows on the strip
before i worked with chris angel for
many years and i worked in many of his
shows and performed but it's the first
time i've actually doing my own show on
the strip yeah we love that well
congratulations vantachek thank you for
joining us i know it's my pleasure thank
you
all right banach's mind games live 4 p.m
six days per week
dark friday by the way tickets start at
just 29 and just head to the strat.com
to get them jc i'll send it to you um